Oggi sono qui per parlarvi di clima
diritti e frustrazione Sì avete capito
bene frustrazione perché per me è stato
il punto d'inizio di tutto
e frustrazione quella che ho provato
quando i miei compagni di scuola mi
hanno detto che non potevo giocare a
calcio con loro perché era una ragazza
ora non è che sapesse giocare bene Le
poche volte che ero riuscita a farmi
includere devo essere sembrata la cosa
più buffa e goffa che si sia vista sul
campetto della scuola ma mi ero
divertita tantissimo però se non potevo
giocare non sapevo come imparare ma
soprattutto Mi sfuggiva cosa c'entrasse
l'essere una ragazza alla fine avevo due
gambe esattamente come i miei compagni
loro non avevano dovuto iniziare da zero
mi chiedevo nessuno aveva portato
pazienza nei loro confronti
Ingoiare il rospo e mi diedi alla più
femminile pallavolo però da allora il
senso di frustrazione verso le
contraddizioni del mondo non mi ha mai
abbandonato Infatti crescendo come donna
mi sono trovata spesso in situazioni che
mi hanno messo in difficoltà e la
società mi ha lanciato segnali e
messaggi che non comprendevo Ma che mi
rifiutavo di accettare credo sia questo
il motivo per cui mi sono iscritta a
scienze politiche relazioni
internazionali e diritti umani Per la
precisione ed è lì che ho trovato anche
la mia passione per le questioni di
genere
è proprio l'università che ho cominciato
a comprendere come tutto nella nostra
realtà sia collegato E come ci siano
delle ragioni sistemiche per le quali
per esempio le donne non hanno ancora
oggi una vera parità con gli uomini e
come questo a sua volta sia spesso
collegato al clima e all'ambiente perché
dovete sapere che
10/15 anni fa non si parlava di clima
Come per fortuna si vede fare oggi
ciononostante arrivavano notizie
veramente allarmanti mi ricordo le
immagini della siccità che ha colpito
l'Etiopia tra il 2002 e il 2003 O quelle
dello Stato d'emergenza durante
l'uragano Katrina negli Stati Uniti nel
ma non mi serviva guardare lontano per
preoccuparmi Ho visto con i miei occhi
le conseguenze dell'alluvione che ha
colpito la regione Veneto nel 2010
coinvolgendo anche la mia città Vicenza
preoccupata e allarmata dai disastri che
vedevo succedere Nel mondo mi chiedevo
come era possibile che l'ambiente
condizione fondamentale per il godimento
di tutti i diritti umani non fosse una
priorità politica come era possibile che
non fosse ancora stato riconosciuto come
un diritto umano e perché quando si
parlava di clima se ne parlava soltanto
in termini tecnici scientifici e nessuno
parlava dei suoi impatti sociali
Ed ecco che tornava il senso di
frustrazione Ma che mi è stato utile
perché mi ha fatto capire nel tempo che
non ha assolutamente senso occuparsi
della protezione dei diritti umani se
non si prende in considerazione anche la
crisi climatica ambientale
Per questo ho deciso di approfondire le
mie conoscenze in questo settore
cercando collaborazioni con
organizzazioni che fossero disposte a
lavorare in maniera intersezionale
ovvero prendendo in considerazione le
cause e conseguenze dei cambiamenti
climatici come una sovrapposizione di
diversi fattori
perché se pensate che il cambiamento
climatico abbia le stesse conseguenze
per tutti ovunque vi sbagliate il
cambiamento climatico esaspera le
condizioni di ineguaglianza già presenti
nelle nostre società colpendo alcuni
gruppi più di altri un esempio le donne
Le donne sono generalmente più soggette
alla povertà e tendono a risentire
maggiormente degli impatti dei
cambiamenti climatici
questo perché il clima tende a combinare
i suoi effetti con quelli per esempio
della minore considerazione
professionale o del relegamento a ruoli
di cura tradizionale che vanno a
sommarsi ad altri fattori su cui come
individui non si ha nessun controllo
come la propria nazionalità razza ed
etnia o il contesto socio economico
culturale da cui si proviene
un esempio pratico di questa
sovrapposizione di elementi ce l'ho ce
l'ho da ancora una volta l'uragano
Katrina che vi ho menzionato poco fa che
non solo ha lasciato enormi danni
economici ma anche un profondo disagio
sociale soprattutto sul fronte femminile
e nella comunità afroamericana uno
studio dell'università del New Jersey ha
dimostrato come successivamente al
cataclisma a New Orleans ci sia stata un
impennata della povertà e di come metà
delle famiglie a rischio fosse composta
da madri single afroamericane Ma questo
è soltanto un esempio di come il
cambiamento climatico possa esasperare
le condizioni di disuguaglianza e
portare ad ulteriori violazioni dei
diritti umani fattore
particolarmente grave se si considera
l'inazione dei nostri decisori politici
Non abbiamo ancora riforme profonde e
sistemiche per una transizione verso
fonti di energia rinnovabili e forme di
produzione sostenibile
per questo è fondamentale
mobilitarsi difendere l'ambiente e
promuovere l'azione climatica nelle
strade e nelle arene decisionale Ed è
proprio quello che fa la società civile
l'insieme di movimenti organizzazioni
non associati ai governi che in questo
momento sta lavorando per far sentire la
propria voce davanti all'evidenza della
Scienza e alienazione dei governi Le
organizzazioni della società civile
possono accreditarsi presso il
segretariato della convenzione quadro
sui cambiamenti climatici delle Nazioni
Unite questo per poter accedere ai
negoziati e monitorarne lo svolgimento
un lavoro assolutamente fondamentale in
questo momento storico ve lo posso
assicurare
è del motivo per cui nel 2015 ho deciso
di unirmi un'organizzazione accreditata
presso il segretariato e ho cominciato a
partecipare ai negoziati come
osservatrice della società civile
collaborando anche con la Women and
Tender costituency Ma che cosa sono le
costituens sono gruppi che mettono
insieme organizzazioni con obiettivi
comuni hanno diritto di accesso e
monitoraggio di parte dei negoziati
possono intervenire ma soprattutto
possono interagire coi decisori politici
presenti per cercare di influenzarne
positivamente l'operato
è proprio all'interno della Women and
gender costituency più conosciuto una
delle persone che più mi ha ispirato e
miglia reyez direttrice ad equità del
genero e grazie a lei Si ho capito la
vera complessità che richiede trovare
soluzioni comuni ma soprattutto acque ai
cambiamenti climatici
Emilia sta dedicando la sua vita a
ribaltare la narrativa di una parte del
mondo la nostra che non ancora fatti i
conti con le responsabilità del proprio
passato Ovvero lo sfruttamento
indiscriminato
dell'epoca coloniale e delle rivoluzioni
industriali causa principale dei
cambiamenti climatici
ed è qui che troviamo la più grande
contraddizione della crisi climatica i
paesi che meno hanno emesso stanno già
subendo le maggiori conseguenze dei
cambiamenti climatici e che grazie ai
paesi del cosiddetto Nord globale hanno
meno risorse per farvi fronte
grazie ad Emilia e alle altre persone
che ho incontrato i negoziati ho
imparato tantissimo sul legame tra
diritti umani e clima con loro ho
passato ore infinite dentro le aule
negoziali dando il miglior contributo
che potessi dare per quanto piccolo
chiedendo Maggiore ambizione per la
riduzione delle missioni ma soprattutto
per l'integrazione di principi dei
diritti umani all'interno dei testi
negoziati
questo perché uno dei problemi dei
trattati internazionali e che devono
essere approvati per consenso e questo
comporta che i loro testi siano spesso
estremamente generici e quindi soggetti
a un'ampia interpretazione
il rischio nel caso dei negoziati sul
clima e che vengano implementati i
progetti e politiche che si
contrappongono alla tutela dei diritti
umani e degli ecosistemi
un esempio sono le mega dighe
idroelettriche come quella del pelo
Monte nell'amazzonia brasiliana
strutture come questa sono sinonimo per
le popolazioni indigene di etnocidio e
perdita completa degli ecosistemi che
sostengono ogni aspetto della loro vita
ed è per questo che è fondamentale che
principi dei diritti umani vengano
inseriti all'interno dei test negoziali
Perché hanno la funzione di tutele
sociali ed ambientali
si assicurano che alla riduzione delle
missioni vada di pari passo la tutela di
diritti ed ecosistemi in modo che
nessuno venga lasciato indietro e che si
lavori veramente per la creazione di una
vera giustizia climatica
Purtroppo però questo non è abbastanza
uno dei nodi più Spinosi dei negoziati e
il cosiddetto perdite danni o Loss and
damage ovvero un meccanismo finanziario
assicurativo attraverso il quale i paesi
Già colpiti dai cambiamenti climatici
dovrebbero poter avere accesso a Fondi
finanziario compensativi per far fronte
ai danni subiti se ne parla da forse 30
anni ed in azione dei governi è
desolante ma è l'ossendomage rimane una
questione chiave strettamente legata ai
diritti umani alla realizzazione della
Giustizia climatica che potrà trovare
una soluzione soltanto quando i governi
ricominceranno a lavorare insieme in
maniera più solidale
Ma cosa è necessario quindi che venga
fatto per rilanciare l'azione climatica
è necessario
è necessario Maggiore ambizione da parte
dei governi per la riduzione delle
missioni ci vogliono ci vogliono
maggiori fondi per la finanza climatica
soprattutto dai paesi del nord globale
del mondo ma è soprattutto è importante
cancellare il debito del Sud globale il
dato di secoli di sfruttamento coloniale
e imperialismo economico
gli ultimi negoziati sul clima si sono
conclusi questa mattina 20 novembre e a
quanto pare purtroppo non abbiamo ancora
un accordo sufficientemente ambizioso e
purtroppo non abbiamo sufficiente tempo
ce lo dice la scienza dobbiamo
accelerare la verità è che dobbiamo
trattare la nostra situazione per quello
che è una crisi una vera e propria
emergenza come è successo durante la
pandemia dobbiamo scardinare i dogmi del
nostro sistema economico per rimettere
al centro quelle che dovrebbero già
essere le nostre priorità ovvero il
clima l'ambiente e i diritti
Se ripenso al 2015 Prova ancora un
enorme senso di speranza ero a Parigi e
avevano trovato un accordo per il clima
e c'era un enorme voglia di fare
da loro ho partecipato a nuovi negoziati
e sono stati fatti anche dei passi
avanti anche grazie alla società civile
ma non basta perché purtroppo Individua
e società civile non possono sostituirsi
all'azione di governi e nazioni
credo che possiate capire come mai negli
ultimi anni il mio senso di frustrazione
ne possa essere aumentato e oggi ho
voluto parlarvene nella speranza che lo
facciate vostro ma spero anche di avervi
comunicato la gioia e l'entusiasmo che
ho provato nel contribuire al lavoro
della società civile ai negozianti
vorrei lasciarvi facendovi riflettere
sul fatto che i sistemi sono fatti per
evolvere e che un cambiamento positivo
Perché inizi è responsabilità e
interesse di tutti e che questo può
partire anche da un campetto di calcio
L'importante è non rimanere indifferenti
e unire gli sforzi ed è per questo che
vi chiedo di agire per il clima in
qualsiasi modo possiate ma soprattutto
sostenete quei decisori politici che
metteranno al centro della loro agenda
il clima l'ambiente i diritti monitorate
il loro lavoro e metteteli sotto
pressione se non si renderanno artefici
del cambiamento necessario per creare un
mondo più sostenibile ed equo per tutti
Ovunque grazie
[Applauso]